Twitter bots are such a big deal that Elon
Musk put his Twitter purchase on hold just
to figure out how many bots or fake accounts
exist on Twitter.
He put the deal on hold in mid-May to figure
out if Twitter was underreporting the number
of fake accounts on its platform.
Fake accounts pretend to be someone else or
are automated accounts that don’t have a
real person behind them that can do things
like real humans can do: send out tweets,
like, and retweet.
There’s apparently even a market for fake
Elon Musk Twitter accounts!
This is important because it is the number
of real users that determines the value of
Twitter.
So if Twitter’s 229 million daily active
users are not 229 million real human beings,
then Musk argues the company's value is less
than the $44 billion he’s agreed to pay
for it.
Musk decided it wasn’t worth it to buy Twitter
for $44 billion because its 229 million daily
active users don’t represent 229 million
real human beings.
Musk tweeted that 20% of Twitter consists
of fake or spam accounts, though he didn’t
cite any sources.
That contradicts Twitter’s claim that fewer
than 5% of accounts on its platform are fake.
Musk says he wants Twitter’s CEO Parag Agrawal
to show proof.
And that the “deal cannot move forward until
he does.”
That wording is much stronger than his previous
tweet that he was “still committed to acquisition”
hours after putting the deal on hold.
When Musk appeared on the All-In-Podcast in
May, he again questioned Twitter’s claim
that less than 5% of its accounts are fake.
Said another way, the number of real-unique
humans that you see making comments on a daily
basis on Twitter is above 95%, that is what
they’re claiming.
Does anyone have that experience?
Hahahahaha
HAHAHAHAHA
Really?
There’s a bridge I’d like to sell you, y'know.
He also likened his agreement to purchase
Twitter to agreeing to buy a home that the
homeowner said had only 5% termites.
Only to later realize it’s infested.
And the whole deal may need to be reconsidered.
A software company found the number of fake
or spam accounts is four times higher than
Twitter’s estimate.
SparkToro analyzed profile pictures, location
data, and used machine learning processes
to conclude 19% Twitter accounts are fake
or spam.
Larger accounts are even harder hit.
SparkToro said 43% of Joe Biden’s Twitter
followers on his personal @JoeBiden account
are fake and inactive.
It’s even higher for Elon Musk: the company
says 70% of his followers are fake and inactive.
Why does the number of fake and spam accounts
matter so much?
Someone who wants to manipulate public opinion
could create hundreds of fake accounts to
criticize a policy or a politician to influence
how you vote, hype a product to control what
you buy, or, make someone seem more or less
popular than they really are.
A cybersecurity researcher believes bots are
responsible for what he calls the attempted
character assassination of Elon Musk.
Andrea Stroppa notes they’ve been tweeting
out “Elongate SpaceX scandal” in reference
to the SpaceX flight attendant who has accused
Musk of sexual assault, which Musk denies.
They’re not just interacting with Musk’s
critics but also his fans….so that conversations
can reach a wider audience rather than the
“echo chamber” of Musk haters.
Fake and spam accounts are influencing public
discourse inauthentically as they don’t
represent the views of real people.
There are things you and I can do to try to
remove bots from our feed.
Stroppa suggests muting some of your Twitter
notifications….for example, from people
who don’t have a profile picture, or who
haven’t confirmed their e-mail address or
phone number.
Musk said one of his top priorities after
taking over Twitter is to defeat spambots
and authenticate all humans, which would dwindle
his followers from 94 million down to 28 million
if it’s really true 70% of his followers
are fake or spam.
But whenever there are fans you can bet there
are critics.
Many liberals have been outraged over Musk’s
push for more free speech on Twitter, which
he believes is being stifled.
For example, he said he’d reverse the platform’s
ban on Trump.
Conservatives have long-accused Twitter of
censoring their views.
A Twitter employee recently confirmed the
apparent left-leaning bias at the company.
This senior engineer was caught in a secret
recording by the right-wing activist organization
Project Veritas saying Twitter does not believe
in free speech, and admitted some of his colleagues
“hate” Musk’s purchase because they’re
“super left”
Another employee also recorded by Project
Veritas made it clear Twitter is not ONLY
about free speech and then proceeded to make
fun of Musk because of his Asperger’s, calling
him “literally special needs”.
Not that poking fun at him would get under
his skin, or criticism of any kind.
Musk said during a TED Talk interview this
year that criticism for his billionaire status
was “water off a duck’s back”.
He’s a man on a mission to deal with bots
and issues of free speech.
If for some reason the Twitter deal doesn’t
end up going through, he could still be a
social media mogul.
He mentioned he’s considered starting his
own app.
We’ve imagined it might be called Elon Social.
If you’d like to build up your skills in
STEM so you can engineer great products, whether
it’s a social app, self-driving cars, or
rockets, Brilliant is an amazing tool to learn
STEM interactively.
Their computer science fundamentals course
will help you strengthen your knowledge of
core computer science concepts and it’s
great if you’re in high school, college,
or already working.
No coding is required and if you’re ever
stuck you can click on “show explanation”
to see where you went wrong.
There’s something for everyone on Brilliant.
You can delve into the world of neural networks
through hands-on experimentation, see fractions,
percentages, and ratios in a new light through
their everyday math course, or learn about
the technology behind cryptocurrencies through
hands-on puzzles.
Brilliant is FREE for you to try out if you
head to the custom link in my description
or pinned comment: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who use my custom
link will get 20% off Brilliant’s Premium
subscription which gives you access to all
of their offerings.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.